let's uh change also to talk about
security on the las vegas strip earlier
this month there was a fight there was a
shooting outside the palazzo
we've talked about metro's efforts to
step up enforcement on the strip dating
back to the summer
is that enforcement level still in place
and where do things stand with regards
to enforcement there
right now um well no we've
we pulled back a little bit it was
called persistent pressure and it was
done
mostly through the summer time and then
we continued it through the fall
to deal with what was occurring on the
strip and everybody's aware of what was
great we had a significant
change in the demographics down on the
strip people were causing
um being unruly releasing anxiety
dealing with uh different issues out on
the roadway versus
inside the casinos seeing that
we adjusted our resources and pushed our
resources to the best of our ability
down there to address the problem
so we affected 1200 plus arrests
uh we recovered 571 guns i believe it is
um and that was directed that was a
direct result
of our proactivity of our police
officers what we expect them to do to
gain control of the situation now the
situation down there is completely
different than what we experienced
earlier in the year or the previous year
and
the crime numbers are bearing fruit
associated with that so
the numbers are positive and what i mean
by positive it's it's good in a good
light
versus being actually positive of an
increase in crime
uh so we anticipate we're going to do
some proactive
uh human trafficking efforts down there
in the
next coming months and and
i would say keep a posture of honoring
at this point
because it's just as important for us to
do enforcement in the neighborhoods and
make sure those resources aren't
depleted in what we do on a daily basis
all right sheriff lombardo thanks again
for joining us this morning we
appreciate